BEST MILITARY ADVICE TO THE
PRESIDENT, SO IT'S VERY
INTERESTING THIS NEXT NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR IS GOING TO BE
VERY DIFFERENT.
>> Chris: WELL, AND LET'S TALK
ABOUT THAT, BECAUSE JOHN BOLTON
WILL BE IN IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS AS THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
WE KNOW HIM VERY WELL AT FOX
NEWS.
HE'S A REAL HARD LINER WHEN IT
COMES TO IRAN AND THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
THAT CERTAINLY SHOULD BE VERY
MUCH IN KEEPING WITH THE
POSITION NOT ONLY OF THE
PRESIDENT BUT ALSO MIKE POMPEO
WHO'S BEEN A HARDLINER AS CIA
DIRECTOR ABOUT THE UTILITY OF
THAT DEAL.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT JOHN
BOLTON WHEN IT COMES TO NORTH
KOREA AND AGAIN, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALL OF THIS HAPPENING WITH
THE SUMMIT.
THINGS COULD BE DELAYED BUT A
SUMMIT THAT IS SUPPOSED TO TAKE
PLACE WITH THE PRESIDENT BY THE
END OF MAY.
>> Jennifer: THERE'S NO GREATER
HARD LINER ON NORTH KOREA THAN
JOHN BOLTON.
HE WROTE "THE LEGAL CASE FOR
STRIKING NORTH KOREA FIRST" SO
HE HAS PUT OUT THERE THE
POTENTIAL FOR A PREEMPTIVE
STRIKE AGAINST NORTH KOREA.
I'VE HEARD HIM SAY ON MANY
OCCASIONS THAT HE DOES NOT THINK
TALKING TO NORTH KOREA WILL
WORK.
IT WILL NOT LEAD TO
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
PENINSULA.
JOHN BOLTON WAS INVOLVED IN THE
'90S WHERE, YOU KNOW, HE WAS
BURNED BY THE NORTH KOREANS IN
THE PAST, AND SO HE IS NOT
SOMEBODY WHO IS GOING TO TRUST
THAT TALKS ARE GOING TO LEAD TO
THE DENUCLEARIZATION.
ALSO, WE HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT
DATE COMING UP IN MAY IN TERMS
OF THE IRAN DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS INDICATED THAT
HE MAY LET THAT DEAL LAPSE, AND
I CERTAINLY THINK THAT JOHN
BOLTON WOULD AGREE WITH HIM ON
THAT.
YOU HAVE A REAL DAISY CHAIN OF
CHANGES WITHIN THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ROLES SURROUNDING THE
PRESIDENT, AND IT CERTAINLY IS
LEANING MORE TOWARDS ALLOWING
THE IRAN DEAL TO LAPSE AND A
HARD LINE ON NORTH KOREA.
>> Chris: LET ME JUST PICK UP
ONE MORE TIME WITH YOU ON THAT,
JENNIFER.
IN TERMS OF THE HARDLINE TOWARDS
NORTH KOREA, IS THAT GOING TO BE
A HARDLINE BUT STILL A SUMMIT,
OR IS IT SUCH A HARDLINE THAT
THE AMBASSADOR BOLTON, TO SOME
DEGREE, AND WE'RE SPECULATING
HERE, MIGHT BE TRYING TO
PERSUADE THE PRESIDENT NOT TO
SIT DOWN WITH KIM JUNG UN FOR
WHAT WAS GOING TO BE AN
ABSOLUTELY UNPRECEDENTED
MEETING, THE FIRST TIME ANY
AMERICAN PRESIDENT MET WITH A
NORTH KOREAN LEADER.
>> Jennifer -- I think it would
be hard for the president to
back out of that meeting: AT
THIS POINT.
YOU'VE HEARD IT WOULD BE A
TRILATERAL MEETING BETWEEN THE
THREE COUNTRIES SO THE SOUTH
KOREAN PRESIDENT WOULD BE THERE
AT THE SAME TIME.
BUT I CERTAINLY THINK THAT WITH
JOHN BOLTON ADVISING THE
PRESIDENT THAT IS UNLIKELY THAT
IT WILL BE A LONG DIPLOMATIC
PROCESS THAT THEY WOULD ENTER
INTO.
JOHN BOLTON IS VERY SUSPICIOUS
OF THAT KIND OF LONG PROCESS.
HE'S SEEN HOW THAT IS USED AS A
STALLING MECHANISM BY GROUPS
SUCH AS NORTH KOREA.
WHAT IS NOT CLEAR TO ME IS THAT
IF YOU LET THE IRAN DEAL LAPSE,
HOW DO YOU TURN TO THE NORTH
KOREANS AND NEGOTIATE ANY SORT
OF SETTLEMENT WITH THEM
BELIEVING THAT THE U.S. WOULD,
IN FACT, LIVE UP TO AN
AGREEMENT, AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE -- THAT'S THE BIGGEST
ARGUMENT AMONG NUCLEAR EXPERTS
AS TO HOW YOU GO INTO THE NORTH
KOREA NUCLEAR TALKS IF YOU LET
THE IRAN DEAL LAPSE.
>> Chris: THANKS SO MUCH,
JENNIFER.
I WANT YOU TO STANDBY.
IF YOU CAN COME UP WITH ANY MORE
INFORMATION, LET US KNOW AND
WE'LL LET YOU BACK IN.
LET'S GO TO CATHERIN H
LET'S GO TO CATHERIN HER
LET'S GO TO CATHERIN HERRI
LET'S GO TO CATHERIN HERRIDG
LET'S GO TO CATHERIN HERRIDGE.
YOU HAVE GREAT SOURCES IN THE
INTELLIGENT COMMUNITY.
AS I SAID, THERE HAD BEEN TALK
ABOUT McMASTER OUT THERE AND
TALK ABOUT JOHN BOLTON COMING
IN, BUT LATE LAST WEEK OR OVER
THE WEEKEND IT SEEMED THAT WAS
ALL GOING TO BE ON HOLD FOR A
WHILE AND NOW SUDDENLY IT ISN'T.
>> Catherin: I SAW JOHN BOLTON
YESTERDAY AND TODAY AND I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE HE'S ALWAYS BEEN
VERY DISCRETE ABOUT ANY KIND OF
DISCUSSIONS HE MAY OR MAY NOT BE
HAVING ABOUT ENTERING THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I AGREE WITH JENNIFER WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS SHIFT IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE OTHER CHANGES TO
THE CABINET THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS NOW PUT FORWARD.
ON IRAN, I THINK YOU'VE GIVEN
THAT A GOOD TREATMENT.
THE ODDS OF THE U.S. PULLING OUT
OF THE DEAL HAVE GONE WAY UP.
AMBASSADOR BOLTON HAS NEVER BEEN
A PROPONENT OF A DEAL THAT WAS
STRUCK UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ISSUE OF
RUSSIA, AMBASSADOR BOLTON IS
SEEN AS SOMEONE WHO IS CALLING
FOR A VERY AGGRESSIVE POLICY
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
IN FACT, JUST ON HIS TWITTER
ACCOUNT IN THE LAST FEW DAYS, HE
POST BODY HOW VLADIMIR PUTIN HAD
BEEN ABLE TO USE KIND OF AN
INFORMATION WARFARE CAMPAIGN ON
HIS OWN PEOPLE IN ORDER TO
ENSURE VICTORY, AND THEN HE
COULD TAKE THAT SORT OF
SARCASTICALLY SPEAKING AND APPLY
IT TO THE UNITED STATES AND
OTHER COUNTRIES SO HE'S
ADVOCATING A PRETTY AGGRESSIVE
POSITION OR MORE AGGRESSIVE
POSITION WITH RUSSIA.
AND THEN ON CHINA, HE ALSO WAS
TWEETING ABOUT THE NEED FOR A
MORE AGGRESSIVE POSTURE WHICH
WOULD, OF COURSE, BE IN LINE
WITH THE IMPOSITION OF TARIFFS
THAT THE PRESIDENT DID TODAY.
I WANT TO SAY THOUGH SORT OF ON
A PERSONAL NOTE, IT DOES APPEAR
TO ME THAT HE WOULD HAVE SORT OF
A GOOD CHEMISTRY OR CONNECTION
WITH THE PRESIDENT, ESPECIALLY
ON THE ISSUE OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL  AND RELATED
DISCUSSIONS.
I KNOW WITH SPEAKING TO
AMBASSADOR BOLTON ON A NUMBER OF
OCCASIONS, HE WAS DEEPLY
DISTRESSED ABOUT THE UNMASKING
CONTROVERSY AND TO WHICH THE
EXTENT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WERE UNMASKING INDIVIDUALS
EITHER DIRECTLY IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OR ASSOCIATED WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN THE 2016
ELECTION.
HE SAID TO ME THAT IN THE YEARS
HE HAD THAT ABILITY IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, HE ONLY
DID IT A HANDFUL OF TIMES, AND
HE FELT THAT IT WAS BEYOND
SHOCKING THAT THE FORMER U.N.
AMBASSADOR IT WAS ALLEGED HAD
UNMASKED -- MADE A NUMBER OF
UNMASKING REQUESTS, UPWARDS OF
200 IN THE CALENDAR YEAR OF
2016.
AND THEN ALSO AS A FINAL POINT,
HE WAS VERY DISTRESSED ABOUT THE
SPECIAL COUNCIL INVESTIGATION IN
LIGHT OF WHAT HE SAW AS A DOUBLE
STANDARD WITH THE HANDLING OF
THE CLINTON EMAIL CASE UNDER FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
SO A LOT OF AGREEMENT THAT HE'S
GOING TO BE MORE AGGRESSIVE,
MORE HAWKISH.
HE WAS VERY DISCRETE ABOUT ANY
DISCUSSIONS BUT CERTAINLY WOULD
HAVE A LOT OF COMMON GROUND WITH
THE PRESIDENT ON THOSE KEY
ISSUES OF SPECIAL COUNCIL, AND
ALSO THE UNMASKING, WHICH WOULD
BE OUTSIDE OF HIS PURVIEW AS THE